as you've been hearing nato's 30 member
states are holding a meeting in brussels
to discuss how to respond to russia's
attack on ukraine the alliance's eastern
members are concerned about their
security including lithuania which has
now declared a state of emergency nato
is likely to decide whether to deploy
its response force to eastern european
countries as a result
what we have warned against for months
has come to pass
despite all our efforts to find a
diplomatic solution
moscow bears
sole responsibility for the deliberate
cold-blooded and long-planned invasion
we condem russia's aggressions in the
strongest possible terms
and call on russia to immediately
cease its military action
let's bring in our diplomatic editor
james bates he's joining us from
brussels so that is the first meeting of
the nato council since the russian
invasion started james tell us what we
should be looking out for and what we
expect to hear
yeah this is the nato council the main
governing body that makes the decisions
for nato meeting at summit level all of
them leaders 30 leaders from the nato
nations secure video conference most of
them aren't here in brussels uh the nato
secretary general is here and the prime
minister of hungary viktor orban because
he was here from last night from the eu
meeting most of the other european
leaders have gone back to their capitals
interesting that they're being joined by
the eu i think they're trying to show
coordination with the eu
to show i think not just the military
aspects but the punishment aspects on
russia of those eu sanctions two sets of
sanctions in place another one uh being
discussed right now also interesting
that the others that join the meeting
who aren't nato members are
both finland and sweden they are joining
this um meeting which i think would
would um be something that uh the
russians would not be pleased about that
they are getting closer to nato they
also will not be pleased about the vast
number of troops that have been flooding
into europe many from the united states
but also troops being moved within
europe towards the russian border the
one thing that vladimir putin said he
didn't want was nato and more and more
nato troops near his border the result
of his action is more have been deployed
we now have a total of 90 000 u.s troops
stationed in europe just 15 000 of those
in the recent weeks have been moved here
and more military assets including
helicopters and planes announced in the
last 24 hours my understanding from
senior nato officials is that we're
expecting more to be announced from this
meeting but i think there are other
aspects to this that won't be discussed
and won't be mentioned publicly by the
nato leaders i'm sure they're discussing
the latest intelligence on the ground
how long can the government of
their um the government of ukraine the
government can kiev
stay operational when will the fall of
kiev if it does happen when will that
take place and then what would nato do
at that point when it becomes a
different scenario an insurgency a
resistance how would nato support things
going forward i think some of this we're
going to hear about in just over an
hour's time when the nato secretary
general briefs the press but there's
aspects that i'm sure at this stage they
won't want to talk about
james what is your understanding about
uh
and this is something my guess just a
moment ago pointed out uh whether nato
will resume talks with with russia
well nato itself used to have
relations with russia there used to be
something called the nato-russia council
used to even
not in this building in the other old
nato headquarters used to have russian
diplomats permanently stationed at nato
i don't see anything on that like that
happening but in terms of diplomacy
between nato nations and russia it's an
interesting it's an interesting subject
going forward
there is not a state of war between um
between any of those nato nations and
russia ukraine has cut off diplomatic
relations but i'm sure that other nato
nations will need to to have
in the future discussions uh with russia
and clearly there are forums where nato
nations and russia are still talking the
osce in vienna is a forum for the former
countries of the soviet union to discuss
with the west there have been repeated
meetings there they've had to pull out
their monitoring mission that was in
eastern ukraine in the last uh 24 hours
but the other key venue where this
happens is of course at the un uh and
there there are regular discussions and
even now i suspect there are discussions
um away from the cameras in the council
chamber between the us ambassador and
the russian ambassador often those
whispered conversations before a council
meeting can can be very important
conversations worth reminding you that
in a few hours time in new york in the
un security council there is going to be
a vote
i can tell you already the result of the
vote um the resolution condemning russia
will be vetoed by a permanent member of
the security council russia which
currently has the presidency of the u.n
uh security council
but i still think that is an important
moment
because i think it will show
the condemnation of the other nations
and it will show where all of the 15
members of the security council stand
what will china do is it going to vote
with russia or would it as it did in
2014 on crimea will it abstain and other
key nations to watch india will that
abstain or will it vote with um with the
western nations and condemn
russia um and and others potentially
that you've got to watch brazil i think
and maybe the united arab emirates will
they abstain all they don't know all
right we'll be watching out for that
thank you so much our diplomatic editor
james baze reporting from brussels